- [Teacher] Let's say that
you love to eat apples,
and you are going to buy a apples,
so a is the number of apples,
number of apples,
but you also have a budget,
so you have to care about costs,
so let's say C is equal to the total cost,
and let's say that the
price of an apple is $2,
so $2 per apple.
There's several ways that we
can express the relationship
between the total cost
and the number of apples.
One way is if we solve for the total cost,
and we say, okay, the total
cost is gonna be $2 per apple
times the number of apples,
so it's going to be 2a.
Another way that we could rewrite this
if we were to divide both
sides of this by two,
we would get that the number of apples
is equal to cost over two.
These are equivalent
expressions I should say
these are equivalent equations,
but the way they've been written,
make it useful for different scenarios.
For example, on the left-hand side here,
it's really easy to try out different As
and then think about how
that will affect the cost,
and so when it's written like this,
we would call the variable
that it's easy to try
out different values,
we would call that the
independent variable,
and then the one that we
are essentially solving for
that we then spit out a value
after we compute using
the independent variable,
you call that the dependent variable.
You could view it as,
look in this situation,
the cost is dependent
on the number of apples
you choose to eat.
Now, when we wrote it over here,
this looks a little bit different.
Now the number of apples is solved for,
and we compute how many
apples based on the cost,
so this would be a scenario
where you have a budget
and you tell me what the budget is
and I could tell you the number of apples.
So in this situation,
C is the independent variable,
and since we have solved for a,
a is the dependent variable.
This is useful if I give
you a number of apples
and you want to know the total cost,
and this is useful if
you have a certain cost
and then you want to find
out the number of apples.